申し訳ないです これで早速始まります
この前の話はいろいろあってんで
少々難しいところもあったでしょうと思いますが
そういうわけで少々軽く今日は説明いたします
一応テーマとしては知っているつもりということで言い方ですね
今日も一応幸福ということは何なのかということ
で 普通の世界では幸福というのは探せば探すほど遠ざかっていくんです
ということにしてます
我々は昔より今幸福だとは一応
一応言ってはいるんですけど
よくよく見ると ある面では楽かもしれませんだけど
もう取り返しつかない他の面で我々は苦しんでいるんですね
例えばいろいろ豊かんですが
もう金がなくて自殺する人々はいる
食べるものがなくて では同じ日本でしたっても
昔はもうそんなになかったと思いますけどね
食べるものがなくて自殺しましたとかね
時々戦争やらね そういうことがあって
ひどい経済状況がある時はそういうことありましたけど
でない場合はそんなに問題はないし
自然破壊も大きな問題でしょうしね
もう取り返しつかない状態ですね
だから幸福を探せば探すほど
どんどん遠ざかっているという
それから精神的な余裕は豊かさがなくなっているし
みんな突然イカれて怒ってイカれてしまうしね
いろいろことあります
それでまあ 体も対応しないようになっているでしょうしね
電波 磁場 磁場 電磁波ですか
電磁波アレルギーの人々ももう出始めているでしょうし
もし電磁波が受け入れられない
いられない体で生まれたら
もうどうしましょうかと
もういるところはなくなっちゃうんですね
地球上ももう電磁波だらけで
で まあそういうことで何か大変ですよ
では テーマに入って話を続けていきます
人生という自転車に例えています
我々の人生って何か自転車みたいですね
自転車よりも私は二輪車という言葉を書いた
書きたかったんですけど
何か二輪車といえば何か日本語で別な車を考えられますからね
そこで  戦輪というのは幸福になりたいという人々の希望があるんですね
そこで後ろの車は そのために励む
それで我々の人生っていうのは
自転車に例えてみると
戦輪はどんな人でも幸せで幸福で楽しく生きていきたいという
戦輪があって それから後ろから一生懸命こぐでしょうに
それは努力ですね それは幸福になるために頑張っているんですね
ですから この自転車に例えたんです
それで戦輪というのは正しく制御するなら幸福へ到着するはずなのです
で この自転車の人生という自転車の戦輪が
前の車輪がちゃんと制御して管理して目的に向かっておくならば
後ろからただこぐだけで十分ですね
ですから 幸福に行くはずなんです
自転車なので こけることも傷つくことも
疲れてやめることもある
なんで私は自転車に例えるかというと
人間というのは幸福を目指して一生懸命頑張ってはいるんですけど
まあこけてしまう人もいますね
幸福になるところが刑務所で終わるとかね
自殺で終わるとか 処刑で終わるとかね
そういうこけてる人々もいますし
まあ傷つくこともあるしね
いろんなダメージを受けると
自分が必死で幸せになりたいんだけど
その道でダメージを受けたり
傷ついたりもします それもあり得る
あるいは別にダメージを受けなくても
疲れたということで幸福になる前に
みんなもうやめてしまうということもあります
例えば人がある時は一生懸命仕事に頑張って
突然嫌になっちゃって全部辞めちゃうとかね
もう男性の場合はだいたい四十五
五十になってくると結構その恐れがあります
突然うつになってしまって
何もやる気がなくなっちゃうという
ほとんどみんなになるわけじゃないんですけど
たまたまあるんです だから女性にもあるし
全部もう投げ出しちゃって
もうわざと自己破壊の道を選ぶとかね
それはやっぱりまあこいでこいでもう疲れちゃったんですね
人生は どこまでやるのかというね
まあ嫌になっちゃったという
それもあるんですね 自転車に
人生にはね しかし人はほとんど目的に達しないのです
それで我々人生という自転車は漕いで漕いで先へ先へ進んでますけど
最強な幸福に達したというね
旗を揚げた人っていうのはいないんですよ
だから何か問題あるんですね
例えば 前輪は幸福を目指してちゃんと制御しているならば
そんなに難しいことじゃないでしょうし
もう後輪を一生懸命漕げばいいんですよ
それが 単純でしょうね
漕ぐだけのことだから
だから自転車に例えてみると
人生っていうのはそんなに難しいことじゃないんですよし
しかしこの途中でこけないようにと気をつけなくちゃいけない
気付かないように気をつけなくちゃいけないといういくつかあります
そこで 途中で疲れないように
ちゃんとスタミナはどうやって管理するのかって
例えばこのマラソンなんか走る人の場合
一生懸命必死で走ることはしないでしょう
必死で走っちゃうと もうもう二
三キロで前にも終わっちゃうでしょうね
だからそういう人々は
ある一定のスピードで時間と距離を計算しながら最後のところまで走っているんです
ただ走り出しただけで
で マラソンなんかは走れませんね
マラソン走ったことない人は
もしかすると なんだみんな連中は遅いんじゃないかと思って
自分だけずっと先に走るかもしれませんだけど
それで終わっちゃいますからね
そういうことだから この自転車に例えて考えてください
とにかく我々は前輪をちゃんと管理制御して
それはそんなに難しいことじゃない
そこで自分のスタミナを計算しながらのんびりと漕ぐと
そこで途中でこけたりするっていうことは
途中で感情的になったり
怒ったり 失敗したり 欲を出したりとか
いろいろわかりやすいことだからね
そういうことでいい加減な判断
いろんな決断しないで気をつけていれば幸福になるはずなんですけど
それでもほとんどの人々は幸福になるっていうことはなかなかないんです
そういうことで 注意点というのは二つあります
回してください で 前輪制御と目的は知っているのかと
一番目 我々には自転車の前輪の制御
知っているのでしょうかと
それからどこへ向かって走っているのかという目的を知っているのかと
聞いたら幸福 幸せだと言うかもしれませんだけど
本当にその幸福 幸せということが知っているのかと
そこら辺に行けば幸福になるでしょうっていうことはね
正しくないんですよ 人が駅に行く道を聞いたら
まあそこら辺どこへ行ったって駅にたどり着くぞと言ったっても
それは正しい答えじゃないでしょうし
ちゃんとこの道路 これぐらい行って
これで右に曲がって これぐらい行って
これから左に曲がってとかね
正しく道案内しなくちゃいけない
それで我々も人生幸福になりたいという気持ちだけあるのですが
本当にそれを知っているのかという問題がありますね
正業と正業と目的を知っているのかという問題があります
2番目は漕ぎ方は正しいのかということですね
我々の漕ぎ方というのは生き方なんですね
我々やり過ぎじゃないか
あるいは怠けて必要なことをやっていないのではないかとかね
やり方間違っているのではないかという問題もあります
漕ぎ方 その 2つの注意点があります
今日のテーマは先輪の解説ですね
2番目ではないんです
ですから 幸福 楽しみというのは何？という
またいくらかこの前とこの前の話に戻ることになりますが
そういうことは今日のテーマなんです
それで次に行きます で
楽しみの発見ということ
まず私が言いたいのは
楽しみ 幸福というのを発見しなさいということで
まず知っておかないと目的は
しかし 発見するまでもないと思っている
人間というのは楽しくなるのは当たり前で
そんなもう何を発見するんですかと
そう思っているんですよ
仏教 本当にあなた方は幸せって何なのかと知っているのかという疑問が出すんです
しかし 世間は何言っているんでしょうかと
そんなのはもう考える必要ない
もう知っているという態度をとるんですね
楽しみぐらいは知っていると思う
生まれた時からこの感覚が刷り込まれている
そこで私たちの問題というのは
我々生まれてるからもう楽しみが知っているんだよという刷り込みがあるんです
刷り込みはあるのに 楽しみは何でしょうかと聞いたら誰もわからないんですよ
本気で聞いたら本気で答えようとするとわからないんです
楽しみは何でしょうかと
でもみんな当たり前 知っているんだよと
うるさいよと そんなこと聞いたってという態度取っちゃうんです
それは刷り込みの原因なんです
そこで生まれてからと書いても
仏教は輪廻という概念で語りますから
仏教っていうのはもう輪廻転生の話で
だから無始無限なんですね
生命っていうのは 生まれて死んで
生まれて死んでいくんですよ
それは仏教の考え方で
輪廻転生ってあるんだと
だから普通の世界ではもう初めて人間に生まれて
それから死んだらそれっきりで人生が終わるというのは
世の中の多数派の考え方なんです
しかし 仏教はそういうことではなくて
ものには始まりも終わりも何もないんだと
しかし 生命としては頑張れば終わりは作れますが
始まりなんかはもうないとということをとっていますから
やはり無限と考えた方がいいんです
そこで生まれてから刷り込まれたわけじゃなくて
生まれる以前からもう
いわゆる無始なる前からも楽しみぐらいは知っているという態度の生き方をしているんですよ
だから これは何体っていうの問題じゃないんです
我々は無限の過去からも楽しみは知ってるんだぞという態度で生きてきたんです
生まれて死んで 生まれて死んで
生まれて死んで それは一度も楽しみに達した覚えがないんですけど
知ってるんだというふうな刷り込みがあるんですね
こういうのは お釈迦様の考え方はすごい新しいアプローチで今紹介していますから
いくらか覚えておいた方が
これが仏教かということでね
役に立つと思います いわゆる今言っているポイントは
生命というのは無始なる過去から我は楽しみを知っているという態度で生きているんです
だから自分やることに文句を言うとすごく嫌なんです
何言うんでしょうかと
私は自分の幸福のためにこれをやっているんだと
ごちゃごちゃ言うなよという態度をみんな取るんですよ
その態度を取らない人はいない
何かアドバイスしちゃうと悪い
そんなことやめなさいよと言ってあげると
しっかりしなさいよと
なんか言うとうるさいと
すごい態度取るんです
それがもう生命がみんな同じなんです
褒めてくれと だから犬なんかに芸を教える場合でも
ただ褒めるだけでしょ
叱ったりすると全然芸なんかやってくれないんです
人間もそうなんです レベルは
何かもううまく成長して欲しければ
もう褒めて褒めてやらなくちゃいけない
で なんでそんなに褒めることは好きで
しつけは嫌がるのかというと
態度でかいんですよ 我は楽しみが知っている
あんた何言うのかというね
これは今 最近 ここで生まれてから現れた現象じゃないんです
うちの子に限ってそういう態度をとるんだという話じゃないんです
これ 無始なる過去から
無限の過去から 輪廻の中で全ての生命が持っているんです
だから皆様知ってますよ
犬なんかもう褒めるのはすごい好きですよと
他の動物も同じなんですよ
だったら全ての生命が同じことなんです
そこがもう大変な大きい問題なんですね
だからそれを覚えておいてください
なぜ人間がそんなにしつけ
道徳を教えると嫌がるのかと
宗教を教える時でも嫌がるんですね
宗教と言って嘘を言うと喜んで聞くんです
本当のことを言うと 宗教の仕事というのは
人の性格を直してあげて
悪いことをしない立派な人間を作ることでしょうね
それをやっちゃうと もう嫌われる嫌われる
だからもうもう天国に行けるんだぞとかね
もう汝は素晴らしい人やとか何とか言わないと
お祈りさえすれば もう君のことを何でも神様が聞いてくれるんだよとかね
そういうふうにおだて文句を言うと人気がある
では実際はお祈りして何でも叶うということじゃなくて
聖書を読んでみたっても
いいことをしなさいとはっきり言ってますけど
でもそれはもうもうないことにするんです
ですから この世の中っていうのは
まあそういう風になっている
その理由は輪廻にあるんです
輪廻のでも我々にはその刷り込みがありますから
すごい質が悪いんですよ
そう簡単に消えないと思います
だから本当は我は楽しみ知っているんだという
そこが何とかして捨てなくちゃいけないんです
でない限り楽しみにはなりません
子供は私のことを放っておけと言っても
放っておいたらその子はいい人間になるんですかね
わかるわけないでしょうに
だから子供は親に放っておきなさいと平気でわがままを言う場合は
もう親は放っておけないですよ
子供のこと で 子供ものすごく混乱して
喧嘩して逆らったりして
いろんな態度をとる で
我々大人も私のこと放っておけという態度をとるのは
私は私に対して何がいいかとか
という態度なんです 子供同じ態度なの
それ正しくないとわかってるでしょうに
そんなことでは しかし
まあそういう生き方やってます
これをお釈迦様が言ってるもう輪廻の原因は無明でアヴィッジャであると
アヴィッジャっていうのはそういうことなんです
まあアヴィッジャの定義はそれだけっていう意味じゃなくて
それもアヴィッジャをまあ紹介する一つの角度
態度なんですね 従って真の幸福を理解しがたいものになっている
だから答え簡単 本当の幸福って何なのかということはものすごい理解しにくい
幸福でないものだったら
どうだい？もうもうもう
何て焼酎杯でもと言ったら
ああ やっぱり楽しいやと
すぐそこにはもう飛んでいくんです
一杯いかがでしょうかというと
で 本当に幸福言うと もうこんなのは面白くもなんでもないと言うんですね
だから まあこれが幸福だ
これが幸福だと言って
仏教が語ってもわかりません
理解できない 幸福にならざるものは幸福にならないものを言うとすぐ理解する
あ なるほど その通りやと
私はすごく嫌な気持ちなみんな
なるほど よくわかりましたというと
ピタッと私はもう下がるんです
もうダメだと 仏典でも日本訳で読んでも
私はよくわかりましたとか言う人っていうのは
私は全然説法が入りだしはしないんです
もうダメなんです だからそこはすっごいもうタチが悪いもう状態で
これはあなたが悪いっていう意味じゃなくて
これ輪廻の次元で見なくちゃいけないんです
もうどうしようもない
我々はもう被害者なんですね
もう無始なる過去からもう刷り込みで来たんだから
まあどうにもならない
もうどうしようもない被害者になっているんです
だからそこは何とかしてあげようというのはお釈迦様の努力なんです
だからもうもう絶対無理な仕事に手を出したんです
この無明を破るということは
だから最初にお釈迦様はもう説法なんかはするもんじゃないやと決めたのは
これがもう無理不可能と
人間に幸せを教えることは無理不可能やと
と思ったんだからなんです
それぐらい難しいことになっているんです
そういうことで じゃあこれから我々知っている幸福の分析に入ります
それ簡単に理解する方法があります
で 赤ちゃん的人生 これを見ると
人間が思う幸福はどういうものかとわかります
で 幼児も楽しみは知っているはずです
だから生まれ月だから
幼児さえもやっぱり楽しみは何なのかと知ってるんですよ
知ってるようです それは皆様
赤ちゃん見たことが触ったことがあるでしょうに
赤ちゃんは結構あれが楽しい
これが楽しい 知ってるんです
いろんなことを楽しくて手を出したりするし
いろんなものをにじったり口に入れたりもするし
笑ったりもするしね だから何に笑うべきか
何が見たら面白くて楽しいか
何を見たら楽しくないかと
赤ちゃんの時からも知っている
面白いことに 人生を明確に分析して
事実を発見して楽しみを知っているわけではありません
しかし 赤ちゃんがもう何も分析してないでしょうに
なのに楽しいんですよ
だから刷り込みということになるんです
ただ 何かに触れると楽しくなる
母親のおっぱいを口に入るともう楽しくて
すごく楽しくて もうもういろいろことやる
だから何か触れると赤ちゃんが楽しくなるんですから
まあまあそれだけのことなんです
楽しくならなかったら
苦を味わって激しく泣く
楽しくないと思っちゃうと苦しみを味わうんですよ
その時は赤ちゃんの時はすごい明確で激しく泣くんですね
で 母親に触られるのはすごい好きなんですけど
触り方が違うだったらものすごく泣くんでしょうに
それで母親か知ってる人に抱かれると落ち着いてるんですけど
知らない人が抱っこするともう泣き出すでしょうね
だからそこは楽しくないっていう意味なんです
ただ 赤ちゃんが明確だから楽しくない場合はよくわかります
ものすごい声で泣いちゃうんですね
それで だから幼児っていうのは感情が激しい
大人と違って 笑う時ももう精一杯笑う
泣く時も全身の力絞って泣く
もう何といいますか リミットなんかはもうそれは度合い知って適当にとか
それはまるっきりない
いつでも思いっきり精一杯で
だから感情は激しいんです
生まれると同時に幸福論は刷り込まれているように思える
ですから 皆様 輪廻転生がわからない
あるいは私は認めないといった立場でいるならば
これぐらいの理解したっても
生まれる時もうとっくに刷り込まれているという事実だけはわかると思います
仏教は輪廻というところから言ってます
しかし 仏教は正しいと思っている人々っていうのは
ほとんどもう指で数えられるほど世の中で少ないんだから
みんな間違っているという態度でいるでしょうし
ですから そこはそれで構いませんけど
この情報を見てみると
やっぱり楽しみ 幸福論というのは生まれる時は刷り込まれているということだけはわかります
で また赤ちゃんの人生は続きます
で 大人になっていく人間は
幸福論を幼児の時の基礎の上に築き上げる
我々は無批判で無差別でゆっくり大きくなるでしょうに
ゆっくりか早いかわかりませんだけど
なんかあっという間に大人になってる生き方でしょうに
振り返ってみると もう大人になっているという
ですから この生まれた赤ちゃんも幸福論を持っている
それでちょっと振り返ってみると
大人になっている人も幸福論を持っているんだから
大人になると同時に幸福論変わりますけど
結局は赤ちゃんが持っていた基礎の上に築いているんです
私たちが人間の幸福感について真面目に考える必要もありません
で これが我々仏教から言いたいポイントなんですよ
人間にとって幸福感 幸福論
真面目に考える必要はないんだと
面白く冗談いっぱい入れて本書いてるならば
笑うために読んでもいいんだけど
真剣真面目に気にする必要はないんです
するわけないんですよ
ということは 我々はもうただ単に幸福を欲しいと思うだけ
あの このベストセラーの本もいろいろあるでしょうね
これさえ知れば幸福になるとかね
幸福の５つの法則とか
[笑い]いつまでも元気で明るく楽しく生きる方法とか
外国でも結構書いていて
それを日本語訳もあって
もう大変売られていますけどね
くだらん はっきり言えば
微妙な分析って何もない
ただいかに人生をごまかすかということ
そういうことで真面目に例えば幼児も大人もなぜ○○が好きか
なぜ何々が嫌いかとわからないんですよ
皆様もそうでしょう 何が好きなものあるでしょうね
好きなものがあると楽しいでしょうね
それ幸福でしょうね でもなんでそれが好きですかと聞くと
答えはない 例えば何か嫌いなものあるでしょうね
嫌いなものやら人やら
そういう人と一緒にいると嫌でしょうね
例えば自分のことでいうと病気が嫌いでしょ
だから病気になったら不幸でしょ
当たり前の話で でもなんでですかと
もう病気になるのは当たり前だから
それがわからないんです
ああ 嫌だというだけで
痛いんだから嫌だよと言ったっても
平気で時々痛いことやってるでしょうに
楽しい楽しいと言って
それは理由にならない
だから我々は結局 なんであれが好きですか
なんでこれが嫌いですかと聞いたっても
もう大の大人なのにわからない
幼児もわからないんですよ
だから幸福感は厚い霧の中の幻視に過ぎない
ですから 赤ちゃんと大した変わりはないんです
だから世間にある幸福感というのはすごい厚い霧の中で遠く見ているんです
でも英語ではVISIBILITYと言うんですけど
これ日本語わからないんで書かなかったんですけど VISIBILITY
RANGEというのはゼロですね
透明度かな 人生の透明度はもうゼロ
もう霧かかっている これまた厚い
しかし 私たちは遠く見ようとするんです
人は肉体の快楽以外楽しみは知りません
それでもう一つのポイントですね
これはただの文章ではなくて
人が知っている楽しみというのは肉体の快楽なんです
見て楽しい 聞いて楽しい
食べて味わって楽しい
触って触れられて楽しい
というぐらいです それでいいえ
違いますよ あんたそんなくだらんことを
人間そんなバカじゃないよと言いたい気持ちもある人々はいるんですよ
我々はより優れた幸福を目指しているぞとかね
我々はこの世の楽しみはつまらないと思っているんだよと
その代わりに永遠の幸福あるんだよと言ったっても
調べてみると肉体の楽しみの延長なんです
私だけなんで苦労するんでしょうか
皆様もこのいろいろ宗教の聖書とか読んでみてください
で 永遠の話 天国の話ありますけど
彼らも書いているのは肉体の楽しみの刺激の延長なんですね
それが永遠にもらえますと
ですから このだから私はこれ宗教批判じゃなくて
私は言いたいのは 人間知っている楽しみは肉体の刺激に限っているんだということ
例えば宗教の方が神様とよく仲良く話し合って
天国に連れて行かれて全部幸福感を見せてくれても
その人が降りてきて人間に喋っても人間にわからないんだからね
肉体の幸福の延長線としてしか喋れないんです
肉体の刺激 快楽の延長
しか喋れない だから肉体の快楽論だから
別にそんな真面目に気にしなくてもいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
私は ということで そろそろ赤ちゃんの話終わると思います
それで赤ちゃんからそういうことを我々には簡単に学べます
進みます しかし ちょっと違うところがありますね
赤ちゃんの人生 大人より楽しい
でしょ 我々も赤ちゃんの考え方で生きていますが
やっぱり大人よりは楽しいんですね
赤ちゃんは 幼児が大人より楽しく生きているのはなぜでしょうかね
これ理由は次に書いてます
考えなくてもいいんです
まあ脳が開発途上ですよ
赤ちゃんの場合は それで
小さなことからも強烈な刺激を受ける
ある日私はどこかへ出かけようとして
もう出かけたところで
もうまあ歳 歳ぐらいかな
もう歳ぐらいのちっちゃな男の子と
もうお母さんとまた赤ちゃんがもうどこかへ出て行って
赤ちゃんが乳母車にいて
お母さんがもう押していくんです
お兄ちゃんはもう後ろからもう一緒にお母さんとベッタリして歩いていて
そこで下見たら あのアスファルトの上で小さな小さな砂利があった
砂利があったんです アスファルトを入れる時の砂利だから
ほんの小さくて黒くてどうったことないでしょうに
その子はすぐそこで座り込んで
あの砂利を見て面白くて面白くて
一つ取っては見るはもう一つ見たらいっぱいあるんだから
もう我慢できない状態になっちゃって
いろいろあるなとかなんとか言うんですね
それでもお母さんもう結構イッてるんです
その子の私は考えたのは
赤ちゃんにとっては あの
全くも大人から見ればつまらない
どうったことない あの黒い小さな砂利を見ても
砂利を見ても もう刺激いっぱいなの楽しみいっぱいなんです
だから 小さなことからも強烈な刺激を受けるんです
だから楽しいんですよ
大人よりも刺激を与えてくれる情報が幼児には多い
だから小さな子供を刺激する情報といえば
もう何でもいいんですよ
いない いないばあと言っただけでも笑っちゃうんです
だから 子供と世界見ると
もうもう何でも楽しいというか
面白いというか 刺激を与えてくれる
苦があってよく泣いても悲しんで落ち込む余裕はありません
赤ちゃんには 赤ちゃんが泣いても落ち込んで暗くなる余裕がないんです
もうあれこれと楽しいこといっぱいあるんだから
だから面白いというのは
ものすごくもう号泣して瞬時に笑うでしょうに
笑って出た涙ももうびしょびしょ
服ももうそれなのに それ乾くところじゃ顔の方も乾いてないんで
もう笑ってるんです 私はそれ見てもうからかってね
君 なんでちょっと前泣いたんですかと
うん それは聞くのは嫌なんです
そうするとまた嫌な顔するんです
だから答えられない質問になると
子供っていうのは出すと子供はすごく嫌がるんです
しかし 子供の頭を良くしたければ
子供に答えられない質問を次から次へ出した方がいいんです
それもよく知恵が出て
例えばなんで君ちょっと前泣いたんでしょうか？とかね
それが子供に答えられないんですね
だからもう言うはどうったことはないんですよ
何か嫌なことがあったら感情激しいんだから動機はします
するんだけど 刺激はいっぱい世の中にあるんだから
ほんのちょっとのことでまたもう楽しくなってしまう
それだけのこと それは子供にわかるわけじゃないんです
だから大人になるとどうなるかというと
刺激が減り 時間的に余裕が出ると悩む
苦しむ暇が現れる これが大人の問題なんです
我々には刺激が少ないんですよ
シャリ見て楽しいと思う人はいません
大人の中で 何か割れたガラスの破片でも持って
これが綺麗だなとかって宝物にしようとする大人がいないでしょう
どんぐり拾ってポケットいっぱい入れて
それで母親がもうズボン洗おうと思っちゃうと喧嘩する
なくすなよ なくすなよとかね
だからそういうことを大人はしないでしょう
だから大人には刺激が減っているんです
その分余裕があるんで
時間的に で これで結構悩む暇があるんです
悩んだり苦しんだりする暇があるんです
だから人生は赤ちゃんより大人
赤ちゃんの方が大人より楽しい
すごい単純なシンプルな話なんですけど
すごい厳密な人生論はそちら辺であるはずなんです
それから赤ちゃんの人生学べる
とか学ぶべきですかね
まあ間違ってますかな
学べるポイントはありますね
幼児から大人が学ぶべきポイントもあります
知った人 知ってる人にならないことです
1番目 それ学んでほしい
知った人に知ってる人にならない
我々はそうでしょう 知った人
知ってる人でしょ 大人だから
それがかなり仇になるんです
それだから人生は苦しいんですよ
ずっと悩んでるんだから
落ち込んでいるんだから
えらい真剣に物事にもう取り組むんじゃなくて
もう真剣質というかね
大変ですよ だから赤ちゃんから学んだ方がいいんだ
赤ちゃんから赤ちゃんが知った人でも知ってる人でもないんですね
いつでも脳を開発途上状態に置かれて開発すること
それから我々は本当に赤ちゃんのように
幼児のように楽しく生きたければ
自分の頭をね 開発途上状態で保たなくちゃいけないんです
知った人はもう開発しないんだからね
脳が固めるんです だからまだ知らない
まだ知ることいっぱいある
あれも知ろう これも知ってやろう
これも面白い あれも面白いと
いうふうに 限りなく知る世界をね
チャレンジすると楽しいんだ
それで余裕がなくなるんですよ
悩む余裕が 知ると楽しいでしょ
何でもいいんだから 知って知ること自体が楽しいんです
知った時点で楽しくなくなっちゃうんです
これがよく覚えておいてください
知ることが楽しいんだけど
知った時点からはもう楽しくないんです
本っていうのは読んでる途中で楽しいんであって
読んで終わってから楽しくないんです
それがこの発展途上状態の特色なんです
だから大人も子供のようにすごく明るくて楽しく
悩むこと何もなく生きていければ
この脳も全く子供と同じく発展途上状態で置いておくんです
悩む落ち込む暇が消えて活発に生きられる
それだったら そういう人は徐々に無常を理解していくと
自分も世界も常に新しく生まれ変われることが見える
これがなんか関係ないように感じるでしょ？これが真理なんです
どういうことかというと
この発展途上っていうことがこの説明できないみたい
我々は何で知っている態度をとるんですかね
あ あれなら知っていると
これが無常を知らないんだからなんです
物事変わるんですよ 毎日同じ道路を歩いているわけじゃないんですよ
変わるんです でも気づかないでしょ
あ あれは知っている 方向ぐらい知ってるかもしれませんよ
しかし 知るわけじゃないんです
昨日の道路と今日の道路違うんです
脳は開発途上状態で置いておくとそれができるんです
今日からやってみてください
道路に出るたびに 今日はどういう道路でしょうかと
毎日違うんだと 毎日違うとわかるはずなんです
この毎日変わることに気づくと
もう余裕ありますかね
悩む余裕とか あれを知る時点で楽しい
で また同じ道路を見ると楽しくないんです
だから知った時点で楽しみが消えちゃうんです
だからみんなつまらない
毎日ワンパターンでとかね
と思っちゃうんです ワンパターンにはならない
何一つ だから脳を開発途上状態でして
まず大胆なことしなくてもいいんですよ
もうあれも面白い これも面白いとかね
この本も読んでみよう
あの本も読んでみようとかね
そういう低次元で もうだらしないやり方でもいいんです
そういう低次元なだらしないやり方であれこれやとか
知識を集めていくと どんどん脳が開発して
もうちょっと観察能力は上がるんです
そうすると花 この花とこの花が同じ 1輪の1輪と言わない一つの何て言いますか
1本の中で花が 2つ3つあるでしょうね
それで あ これはバラ これは何とかと
これはカーネーションとかね
言った知った態度でしょ
でもカーネーション 1本取っても花が三つ四つはついてるでしょうに
1本1本違うでしょうに
そうやってこの小さな差でも
あ これだこれで これはこれでという見るともうもうもう限りなく全て差なんです
それで楽しくなるんです
それでさらに持っていくと
もう毎日全部変わって
同じ道路は二度と歩けないんだと見えてきます
それで だから無常に行くんですよ
この生き方で 無常に入ったらもう無限に楽しく生きていられます
そこで別なポイント もうあの話それで終わりました
ちょっとタイトル変えるの忘れましたけど
で 知ってる楽しみは過去だ
で みんな生命は 生命たるものは楽しみぐらいは知ってるんだという態度でしょ
これが過去なんです 死んだ過去なんです
楽しみは知っている 求めているというのは
単なる無知な感情に過ぎない
楽しみぐらい私は知ってるんだよというと
それは単なる無知な感情です
ただ赤ちゃんの状態でしょ
知らないんです 私は何のために生きているのか
私は楽しみを探し求めて生きているんだと
頑張ってるんだと 幸せになるためにと
バカでしょ 知るわけじゃないんです
幸せになるために私は一生懸命頑張っているんだよと言っても
その人知ってるわけでもないし
ただの感情 それから例一つ説明していきます
私は美味しい蕎麦の店知っているという例
皆様の人生から例を出さないと
日常の 初めて食べてみた時は
固定概念も経験もなく
素直の気持ちでした 例えば
ある日突然どこかに店に入り込んだところで
そこで蕎麦食べてしまった
この店はもう誰がやっているのか
そんなのは知ったものでもないし
ただお腹が空いてただけで
蕎麦屋にいるんだから
まあそうでも食べましょうか
食べようかと すごい軽い気持ちで素直で入っただけ
何も固定概念がない これ大倉ホテルで修行した何さんでしたっけ？コックさんがやってる店とかね
そういう固定概念何もない
で そういう気持ちでした
美味しく感じた時は それは現在の出来事でした
それで蕎麦を食べてると美味しい美味しいと感じる
それが現在 過去じゃないんです
それから執着のおかげで
その過去の経験を覚えておく
そこで美味しいって執着するでしょ？美味しいと
あの執着のせいで覚えていくんです
あの経験を だから無常を先にというのはそういうわけなんです
執着できるはずがないんですよ
この花がなんて綺麗です
花が枯れていくんだから
別な花を見ないと 捨てないと
しかし 私たちは無常を知らんのだから執着する
執着して覚えていくんです
あの蕎麦美味しかったとかね
それで覚えていく 経験を覚えていく
はい 次に行きます それどうなるかというと
それから美味しい蕎麦屋を探す時も
他人に案内する時も 過去の経験に依存している
やれやれということで
美味しい蕎麦を食べたいなと思っちゃうと
あの経験が蘇ってくるんです
人が蕎麦食べたいんだけど
店でも知ってる？知ってるんでしょうか？と言えば
ああ そういえばなんとかなんとか店の蕎麦がいいやと
それは過去の経験なんです
だから我々に他人様がこれが楽しみだ
これが人生の楽しみだというのは
単なる過去の経験ですよ
我々も偉そうな人に説教するでしょ
こうすれば君は幸福になるんだよと
いい学校に入って勉強すれば安定した職業に就くぞ
これは昔話ですけどね
今も言ってるんです だからみんなの幸福論というのは何のことなく過去の経験に依存して言ってることで
それで過去の経験の再現を求める
次のポイント それで私たちたちは幸福だと何を求めてますかね
過去の経験の再現なんですよ
過去の再現 しかし 次のことを読んでみてください
人は時を逆 逆戻しに頑張っている
人間何をやっているのかというと
時を逆戻しにしようと
頑張ってます 巻き戻しにしようと
買って蕎麦食べて美味しかったんだからといって
それから人に言うは言うは
自分でも美味しい蕎麦食べると同じ経験に依存するんだから
過去の経験の再現なんですよ
これは時計の逆戻しなんです
それ書いてないんですけど
時計の逆戻しはありえないでしょ
人生の巻き戻しないでしょ
ビデオテープじゃないんだから
でも我々の幸福論というのは何のことなく人生を巻き戻ししようという
幸福論なんです だから先に言ったんです
世の中にある幸福論なんか役に立たないくだらんこと言って
そこまで考えているのかと
そこまで微妙に この例は考え考えられる他のすべての楽しみにも当てはまるのです
どんな楽しみにしたっても同じことなんです
時間の逆戻しはありえないはず
ありえない話です そんなありえないんです
だからこそ 生きることは苦のみで終了
だってできることに頑張ってるわけじゃないでしょうに
無理に頑張ってるでしょうに
だから大変ですよ 例えば歳若返りとか
これをお化粧したり いろんなもうなんとか目だけ鼻の穴だけ見えるようにいろいろしたっても
年はもう取っているんだから
だからもうすべての人間のすべての生命の人生は苦で終了するんです
なんか手を叩いて空を飛ばおうと飛ぼうとするような感じでしょうに
疲れるでしょうに 点ミリでも上がらないでしょうに
そういう幸福論ですよ
俗世間の幸福論は はい
それからこの過去の罠から抜けるために
それで全ての生命がこの過去の罠にはめられて幸福やと勘違いして苦しんでいる
幸福だとは言い張ってはいるんですが
実際は苦しんで時計戻そうしているんだから
だから抜ける方法はあるのかと
抜ける方これなんです
自分には秒あるいは瞬間の命しかない
我々は瞬間しか生きてないんです
変わるんです 瞬間わからない方々は秒にしてください
でも瞬間というのはもう何千も入ってます
秒の中で 瞬間 瞬間がすごい早い
年は絶えず経過する 自分は絶えず老いていく
だからやるんだったら今の瞬間しかないんです
次年取るんです 時間は戻せません
こういうことを覚えておいてください
人生にはタイムカプセルがありません
同じことを繰り返して書いてるんです
こんなのは夢想家の小説にしかないんです
ゲーム機のリセットもできません
ゲーム機のように ですけど
ちょっと間違いですけどね
だからみんなゲームやってる場合は
ゲームがうまくいかなかったらリセットするんです
またやり直し 初めから
どんなパソコン系のコンピューター系のゲームも何回でもできる
お金入れる場合は やっぱり金が出さない
入れないとできんだけど
ゲームボーイだったらもう死ぬまでできる
上手になるまで でもそれが人生では絶対ありえないんです
リセットはないんです
外の だから自分そんなもんで外の世界も停止しているのではないんです
それで今日見そこな見そこなったんだから
じゃあ明日見ようと ありえないんです
それはできません 明日別
自分も同じスピードで変わっていく
だから外の世界も自分も同じスピードで変わっていくんですよ
それで物理的な話なんですけど
あの 私も隣の人もまるっきり同じスピードで動くと
スピードはいくら早くても分からなくなっちゃうんです
例えば時々ありますね
電車 2本 同じ方向へ一緒に走る時もありますでしょ
そうすると隣の電車が止まっているように見えるんですね
ずっと同じ 止まっていると
でも一つが一つの電車がちょっとブレーキかけた時点で
あれが先に行っちゃいますからね
だから人間にこの無常をわからないそちらもあります
花を私はずっと見ていると花が枯れていくんですよ
同時に私も年取っているんだから
枯れていくこと見えなくなっちゃうんです
だから それを瞑想でもしないと
この時間を ずれを作らないとね
大変な仕事です 瞑想する人々はもうこの時間がずれるんです
ずれちゃうんです それで変わっていくんだ
そこでわかるんです 普通の人にはできない
人生は一期一会です 一期一会
私の漢字間違っていたっけ
それからも同じ漢字書いてやったんですけど
そういうこと だからそれわかればもう抜けますよ
この過去の罠から 幸福論買えますよ
あの店の蕎麦が美味しかったんだから
その生き方やめるんです
過去に執着しないことになります
現在のみやと すごい楽になるんです
はい それからもう一つポイントを気づかれます
楽しみは期待して得られません
この期待して得るっていうのは過去なんですね
何か楽しみになりたいと期待して何か計画立てるでしょ
あれが過去の経験の再現でしょうに
それ起こらないでしょ
永久的に 時間戻せませんから
だから楽しみということは期待して得るものじゃないんです
だから仏教は期待に反対です
期待する楽しみは過去なのです
外れるに決まっている
期待も希望も計画も固定概念も先入観も
余計なことをいっぱい書いました
テキストもマニュアルもない
一期一会で刺激も楽しみも現れる
一期一会です 一期一会だったら期待もないでしょ？希望もないでしょ
別に計画もないでしょうに
固定概念 先入観でも起こるものじゃないでしょうに
あるいはテキスト 幸福になるテキストとか
何もない マニュアルもない
だからもうすぐ突然楽しくなったっていうことなんです
だから期待なければないほど楽しいんです
食べた蕎麦は美味しかったのは良いが
例えばセバネリに戻ると期待もせず突然行った店で食べた蕎麦はすごく美味しかったと
そこまでいいんですよ
また同じものを食べたくなるのは愚か者です
それから馬鹿をやるんです
幸福にならない人です
だからこの一期一会っていうことが
この仏教の日本でよく人気ある言葉で
これは仏教用語なんです
無常を表現している言葉なんです
それは実際使ってる中国
日本系の法様の方々はそれを知らない
これでこの絶対的な無常を表しているすごい言葉だと
文学的な表現だと勘違いしています
だから蕎麦が美味しかったのは一期一会なんです
そこでもあんたもあのお店に行って食べなさいよと
で 自分もそれからもう日本中そば店を探検するそうと言って
日本中そばの店食い歩く人いるでしょうと
楽しくないんですよ いつでも過去の再現なんです
しようとしているんです
だから仏教から見れば
もう本当にもう正真正銘の愚か者なんです
だって時間戻さないでしょうに
こんなのありえないでしょうに
はい それでまあ一部の結論ですけど
楽しむためには向きを変えるという
またタイトル変わります
また別な話 もし人生楽しいたく
楽しみたければ向きを変えてほしい
知識も あ 知識のですね
え？知識の目は 知識の目は後ろ向きに我々過去についている
我々生命に見る目があるんですよ
残念なことに それは後ろについているんです
なんか蛇で考えてください
蛇の目はしっぽの方にあって
でも蛇は前に体が前の方向に向いて前に行かなくちゃあかんでしょう
だから今まで説明したのはそういうことなんです
だから人間言ってる幸福論というのは過去論であって
過去を取り戻す 論であって
過去はいかに再現できるのかというありえない話であって
だから人間の目は後ろ向きなんです
というか 後ろ向いて付いているんです
目っていうのは肉体の目ではなくて
ものを知る目なんですね
仏教がそれを足元 今現在を見られるようにと位置調整をしようとしているのです
そこで仏教は何をやろうしているでしょうかというと
この後のみ見ている人間の知恵の目を
知識の目を足元見るようにと位置調整しようとしているのです
で なんで足元ですかね
これも今日は長いんだからこの経典引用できないんだけど
将来も見てはいけないんです
過去だけダメなわけじゃないんです
将来もダメなんです なぜかというと
将来は現れてないんです
いわゆる存在しない 考えたって何の意味もないと
例えば私の子供は男か女か知ってますか
どちらかでしょう 男か女でしょうね
どちらですかね  分かりません
生まれてきてない  だからそういうことなんです
私には子供がいないんだから
で これには男でも女でも答えられません
だから   もう年だからこれから子供作るっていうこともないんですけど
だってもしそういう あの
何て言いますか 可能性ある人の場合でも
例えば若い女の子を見て
あなたの最初の子は男ですか？女ですか？と聞いたら
まだ結婚もしていないんだから
答えられないでしょうに
だから将来は現れてないんだから
見ようとしても見るものがないんです
だから仏教は将来見ることも禁止するんです
過去を見るのも禁止するんです
足元を見ます アティータンナーンワーガメイヤ
ドゥノットランアフターザパストという
過去を追うなよと ナッパティカンケーアナガタン
ノーエクスペクテーションズフォーフューチャーという
将来に対する期待しなく
しなく するなかれ 理由はヤダティータンパヒーナンタン
ワティスパストイズゴーンフォーエバー
過去たるものは永久的に消えているんだよ
もう戻せません アッパッタンチェアナガタン
フューチャーイズノットイェットマニフェスト
将来ということはまだまだ現れてない
もうわからない どうなるか
アサンヒーランアサンクッパン
あちらにこちらに引っかかることなく
混乱することなく パッチュッパンネスダンメス
タッタタッタヴィパッサティ
現在のことのみ客観的に観察するんだと
それでアサンヒーランアサンクッパン
何ものにもとらわれることなく
混乱することなく生きていられますと
これが賢者の生き方であるというところなんですから
まあもう経典は全部裏に隠れていますから
もう表に出すわけにはいきません
で 仏教はよく覚えてください
2行目は仏教が何やっているのかというと
この過去しか見られない我々の知恵
知識の目を足元見られるように
現在見られるように位置調整しようとしているんです
それで幸福になります
過去を見る限りは幸福にはなりません
死んでいる 実際しない
二度と現れない過去を追うことは
人がイメージする幸福
楽しみです それで人がイメージする幸福というのはそういうものです
過去を追うこと でももう死んでいるんです
過去は 実際もしない 過去に似た経験がたまたま起こることで
人は生きることは幸福だと大声で言うふうです
時々過去と似た経験が起こります
でも同じじゃないんです
みんな毎年桜の花見るのはそういうことなんです
あの去年のは何となく似てるんです
別なんですけど 自分は一年も年取ってるんだから
あのほんのちょっと似たことで喜び感じちゃうんですね
似ただけで だから本物の喜びじゃないんですよ
あれは偽物で喜ぶんだからね
だから人間はなんで自分の幸福に後ろめたさ感じないのかっていうことは
仏教の疑問なんです その代わりに仏教に対して後ろめたさを感じるんですけど
困ったもんで 例えば皆様方はこの偽のブランド品のカバンを持って胸を張って言っていると
もう偽物ということがバレバレだったら
これも恥ずかしいもいいところでしょうに
実際そういうことなのに
我々幸福というのはこの過去と少々似ている
これで幸福だというので
だから人間その時点で楽しみ感じるんですね
事実はまあそれだけのことで
だからあんまりにも声がでかすぎ
世の中のこの幸福論に対して言っているのは全然当てにならないいい加減なことなのに
誰も発見してないんですよ
これは過去の再現であるということは
私は読んでいる限りはないんです
これ ブッダしか知らないみたい
なのにもう声がでかすぎですよ
世間にある幸福論は そんなにでっかい声で幸福論
幸福論 幸福になりましょう
言うなら言うならば幸福になっているはずでしょうに
でも一人もなってないし
それで最後の行 事実は楽しみは最小で苦は最多であること
だから我々の世の中で人生評価してみると
楽しみっていうのは最小であって
苦しみは最多なんです
これは実態なんです やっとの楽しみでしょうと
これもなんでやっとの
それも過去に過去の経験にちょっと似ている
それだけのこと それも仏教から見れば偽物
本物の楽しみじゃない
だから期待も計画もなし
希望もなし 突然出会った楽しみほど素晴らしいものじゃないんです
だって例えば期待も何もしない時
何かいいことが起きちゃうと
我々はもうもう倒れるほど楽しいでしょうに
もう声も出なくなるでしょうに
それが本物です あの瞬間だけ
それで無常を知らんだからあれに執着するんです
それからもう地獄 はい
ああ もう半分しか言ってないんです
早く行きましょう 人生の進む方向
人は前に進んでいない
だから人は前に進んでいるわけじゃない
過去に囚われているんですね
過去に囚われているんだから前に進んでないんです
いつでも過去を取り戻したい
過去を取り戻したいという生き方をしているんです
したがって 自由も刺激もインスピレーションも新鮮さもなく
知識は生きたまま死んでいるのです
我々は過去に囚われているんだから
自由もない インスピレーションも出てこない
子供みたいに刺激もない
知ってるんだという態度取るんだから
だからどうなってるかというと
知識は我々の知る能力は
もう死んでるんです 生きたまま
なんで私は生きたまま死んでるという変な言葉を使ったんでしょうかというと
私はこの日本語わからないということではなくて
計算して書くんですよ
生きたまま死んでいる
だから死んでいるか生きているのか
どちらでしょうかね 論理的には生きたまま死んでいるという文章って成り立たないんです
なぜそれを書いたのかというと
死んでいるというと もう手上げでしょ
だから仏教がもうちょっと穴がありますよと
明るい この闇から破れる抜け道がありますよということ
だから生きたままのところを
だからわざと置いたんです
置いたんです だからまだまだ見込みはないわけじゃないんだと
でも知識は死んでいるんですけど
まだ生きたままだから
まだ生き返してもらうことはできます
この生きたまま死んだ状態は
仏教で言う怠ること タマード
態度なのです お釈迦様はずっと言っているのはこのアッパマーダ
不放逸で頑張りなさいと
お釈迦様は涅槃に入った瞬間で最後に言ったことも言葉もアッパマーデーナサンパーデーナ
不放逸で怠ることなく励みなさいと
だから いかにこれ大変大事なことかと
我々は過去に囚われている
過去に囚われているんだから前に進めない
だから新しいものあるのにわからない
無常で全部変わっているのにわからない
その囚われている状態は死んだ状態だとお釈迦様は言うんです
イエパマッタヤタマタ
パマッタの人がパマードの人はもう死んだも同然だよと
人は後ろを見て前に進むのです
人間のやり方は後ろ後ろを見て前に進むって
もういけるわけないんですよ
怪我するに決まっている
はい で 囚われた生き方についてブッダの言葉なんですね
過去に執着する生き方
囚われた生き方で囚われた生き方です
そこで 今まで人間の幸福論というのは過去に執着することで
それは囚われた生き方です
自由がなく 苦しむことになる
そうすると苦しむことになります
ありえないことだから
ものは変わらないと思って生きている人は苦しい
人に苦しかないとセクションが説かれる
みんなものは変わらないと思っているんですよ
つまらないとか 毎日同じことだと
あるいは逆に思うんですね
我々には永遠たる魂があるんだそうと
私が死んだら永遠にブッダのなんとかどこかに行くぞと成仏するぞとかね
そうやって変わらないと思ってるんですね
その人には苦しかないんです
この変わらないという時点で
我々は過去に行くという信じられない出来事が起こるんです
過去の再現ということ
時計の逆戻しということ
これがありえないんです
無常を認めない人は永遠魂がなどの観念を持てあそぶ
だから無常を認めないバカどもたちは
いろいろ宗教やら哲学やら
もうあれこれ作って ものすごい難しい
もう読んでも読んでもわからない
本まで書いたりしてもうもてあそんでるんですよ
自分の人生を 苦しいなのに
勝手にいいんだけど 私たちに言うんだからね
これを真面目にこちらを受けますからね
もう大変です お釈迦様があの経典でサンタラバーヒラバンドナバッドアティーダッシー
アパーラダッシー バッドジャーヤティバッドジーヤティバッドミーヤティ
バッド なんか間違ってますね
これHはbadなんですよ
書き換えましょう BのところにあるHはDDの後ろに行くんです
ちょっと待ってください
もう直せます 全部 あの
いくつかありますね はい
バッドジャヤティバッドジーエティバッドミーエティバッドアスマロカパランロカンガッチャティ
このサンタラっていうのはちょっと前の文章もありますし
前置きもあります それに繋げていますけど
俺はアントラバーヒラというパーリ語を知っている方々は読んでみてください
サアンタラ アンタラっていうのは中
内 自分の中 バーヒラっていうのは外の世界
バンダナバッド もう囚われている
結ばれているという バンダナっていうのはジョイント
もう もう何て言いますか
結ばれているという 囚われている
我々は内の中でも囚われている
外にも囚われている 例えば楽しみというのは体に生まれるものだから
体に囚われているでしょうね
それでご飯食べて楽しいんだから
ご飯にも囚われているんですね
だから内も外も囚われていて
バンダナバッド アティーラダッシー
この囚われているこの状態からこの乗り越えることは知らない
わからない 過去に囚われていることからどうやって抜け出すかということは
これはもう想像にも入らない出来事なんです
アパーラダッシー もう向こうの方あるんだよと知らない
知らないでバッドジャヤティ
生まれる時も囚われの身で生まれる
バッドジーエティ 囚われの身で生きている
年取っていく バッドミーエティ
囚われたまんまで死ぬ
バッドアスマロカパランロカンガッチャティ
囚われたまんまでこの世からあの世にも行く
そこでその世に行ってもまた囚われている
だからもうすり込み論はわかると思います
輪廻から だから囚われたということは
過去に囚われているんです
過去が楽しいということで
楽しみは過去にないんです
だからずっと我々はもう輪廻転生する
だから時間は流れてるんですよ
輪廻転生 しかし 私たちはずっと過去を再現しようと後ろを見ているんです
こちら進んでいるのに
だから生きることは苦一色ですと
これYahooはいい加減に訳は書いてます
自分自身が変わらないものだと思っているということは前置きの文章で
人は内からも囚われて
外からも囚われて 逃げることも自由も知らず
囚われ身で生まれ 囚われ身で生き
囚われの身で死ぬ 再び囚われの身で生まれ変わるということ
これは三日二会という仏典であるです
はい で またあります で
楽しみの研究 それから今は間違ってる楽しみの説明だから
正しい楽しみということも研究しないと
まあこれはまあ仏教からですから早く終わります
何が楽しみのかと ブッダ
ブッダの徹底研究 楽しみは物にあるのではなく
自分が楽しいので それは前の講義で説明しました
カバンが楽しいんじゃなくて
カバン持ってる自分の気分が楽しいんです
自分の心に起こる現象なので
その時点で考えるんです
身体は 5つに分けます
それを五蘊と言うんです
1番目はルーパカンダですね
日本語で色蘊と言うんです
いわゆる肉体ですね ルーパっていうのは肉体
わかりやすい  2番目ヴェーダナーカンダ
感覚ですね 痛いとかね
気分がいいとかね 気持ちいいとかいう感覚
で  3番目はサンニャーカンダ
それはまあそうと書いている概念
あれこれですね 概念 あれこれはサンニャーカンダ
で サンカーラカンダっていうのはこの衝動的なエネルギーなんですね
何かやりたい 何かしたいという
これの専門的な分析ありますけど
ものすごい難しい それでヴィンヤーナカンダっていうのは色心ですね
パーリ語でカンダっていうのは一応もう塊 5つに体を分けてます
1つは肉体的な 物質的な物体
残り残り 4つは精神的なところ
痛いとか感じるのはジュウですね
で 概念やら勉強したものやらそうですね
それからもうまあ生きていきたいという衝動的な
ポテンシャル的な 精神的な力はサンカーラで
心そのものが あれこれと認識する心がヴィンヤーナで
はい 体そうやってお釈迦様分析してからこういうふうに研究するんです
以上の一つ一つについて以下のように研究したのです
で 例としてルーパだけ出します
経典は長いんだから まずルーパのいわゆる物質の楽しみ
快楽 長所を調べる 例えば肉体の楽しみは何なのか
肉体の快楽って何なのか
肉体があっていいところって何なのかと徹底研究する
それはお釈迦様こう言うんです
ルーパッサーハンビッキャアッサーダパリエーサナンアチャレン
このアッサーダということは
ここでポイントの言葉なんです
ローマ字で書いている 3番目の単語ですね
アッサーダ お釈迦様は徹底的に肉体からどんな楽しみがあるのかとはっきりと研究したんです
それでそれを見つけて体験する
ヨールーパサッサードタダッジャガマン
この肉体から得られる楽しみっていうのは
私はだいたいだいたいではなくて
もう全部経験しているんだよと
その楽しみを智慧によって理解する
それから肉体からどのような楽しみが得られるのかということは
智慧によって分解して明確に理解する
ヤーヴァタールーパサッサードパンニャーネスディット
この肉体から得られるべき得られられるすべての快楽は
私は私の智慧で発見したんだと
それは 1番目のステップ
次の研究は 色のいわゆる肉体の危険性
短所を研究する 肉体は楽しいだけじゃないんです
危険性もあります それを研究するんです
ルーパッサーハンビッキャアーディーナパリエーサナンアチャレン
この色のアーディーナの危険性
悪いところ 肉体の だってガンにもなるでしょうに
例えば音楽聴いて楽しいんだけど
ずっと聴くと耳が痛いでしょうに
悪いところもあります
それは探しましたと はい
それで 3番目に行きます
次 肉体からこの色 色と書いているのは肉体って意味なんです
これ 仏教用語ではそう書くんです
物質って意味なんです
から解放 自由 色のあれ
何でしたっけ？色を研究する
肉体っていうのはいいところもあるんだけど
悪いところも やっぱりこれ捨てる法はないのかと
ルーパッサーハン ビックウェー ニッサラナ パリエサナン アチャリン
これで専門用語はニッサラナなんです
解脱ということ 色から逃げてしまうということ
それを見つけて体験する
そこで肉体から離れることをお釈迦様は体験するんです
ヤン ルーパッサ ニッサラナン タダッジャ ガマン
このニッサラナある解放シャキを私は経験しましたと
あ 間違ったね この楽しみではなくて
このシャキですね そのシャキを智慧によって理解する
シャキとかいったって仏教でいう解脱っていうことなんです
で 智慧によって理解する
ヤーワター ルーパッサ ニッサラナン
この肉体から得られる一切の自由というのは
私はすべて私の智慧で経験しました
このように五蘊も研究する
肉体だけじゃないんですよ
あの感覚もそのように研究する
想 概念 思うこと すべてそうやって何が良いのか
何が悪いのか どうやって概念から抜けるのかと
それを研究する それから衝動的なポテンシャルエネルギーについても
何が良いのか 何が悪いのか
どうすれば抜けるのかという三つも徹底研究する
心についても同じ三つの段階で研究する
このように五蘊も研究する
すべてから解放される自由を獲得する
それでお釈迦様は完全に体ではなくて
五蘊からも解放される
肉体も感覚も想も概念も衝動的なポテンシャル的なエネルギーからも心からも解放される
それがブッダの悟りの研究の内容です
それがお釈迦様の悟りの
それを瞑想で研究したんだから
それで悟ってしまうんですね
それが究極の幸福ということになるんです
そういうことで ブッダはもうやっぱり楽しいのは体でしょうということで
この五蘊 色受想行識という五蘊を調べましょうと
徹底的に調べるときは
長所 短所とそちらから逃げる
両方三つで研究するんです
はい それからもう終わります
世間の見方 これがブッダの楽しみ論 ２
ページで終わりました
で 世間はどう見るかというと
読むだけで十分です 肉体
肉体が快楽を作るという事実にも気づきません
世間は楽しみを探す探すと言っても
これ肉体が作る解釈しかお前知らないでしょということに気づけてないんですよ
肉体から得られる楽しみの質も量も知りません
みんな快楽を求めるんですけど
体の快楽 快楽にも質もあって量もあるんですね
それは知らない みんな
いくら何でも楽しめるわけじゃないんです
それから質もありますよ
楽しいんだからって 例えば麻薬なんか楽しいんだからといってやってはあかんでしょうに
快楽による肉体と精神がどれほど蝕まれるのかとも知りません
そこで快楽を求めると
もう体も精神も蝕んでいくんですよ
これ 誰も知らない 美味しいものを食べれば幸せやと言うんだけど
美味しいものを食べた時点でもう体それで蝕んじゃうんですよ
体壊す 壊さず何もできませんよ
一曲聞いたらそれで耳がかなり壊れますよ
私も眠れない時は音楽流しちゃうんです
一曲終わるともう疲れてもう寝た
もう寝ているんですよ
もう すっごく疲れるんです
俗世間には楽しいことなんですけど
私から見ればあんなに疲れることがあるのかと
結構それも俗世間知らない
快楽を得るためにどれほど苦労しなくてはならないかもしれません
だから俗世間はこの快楽を得るために苦労しなきゃいられないんです
それを知らない 得た楽を得る苦から差し引きもしません
差し引いたところでしょに幸福かないかわかる
それ絶対しないんです
すぐ苦しみを忘れて ちっぽけな楽しみにもう溺れるんです
差し引いてほしいんですよ
はい しかし 楽も幸福も知っていると自慢げに言う
あれほど知らないことはあるのに
自慢げに言うんです 楽しみは知ってるんだと
引き算しないから 苦あれば楽ありと断言する
引き算しない世の中は平気で苦あればもう楽あるんだと
ということで もう我慢しているだけなんですけど
一切は移り変わることに気づきません
だからそれも知らないんだから過去にいくでしょ
楽しみが現れるとそれを停止してもらいたくなる
まあこれは例えばこの花綺麗やと思ったら
それは切って家に持っていって
この花が長生きするようにいろいろ工夫するんですよ
切った時点で花が枯れるのに
それで薬入れたり 水を入れ替えたり
またちょきんちょきんと切ったり
もう半分割っていろんな苦労する
何やってるのって もうどうせこれはもう枯れるもんですけど
人を見たらあの人可愛いと思っちゃうと
とにかく自分のものにしたがるんです
可愛いのその瞬間だけなんです
だから余計なことをするんです
停止してもらおうと 離したくはないと思って踏ん張る
これはみんなに痛い経験があるでしょうね
幸福を離したくないと結構踏ん張るんだから
その努力も苦しみを作る
結局楽しくなった時点でも苦しくなるんです
なぜかと楽しくなったものを止まってもらいたいでしょ
これが苦しいんですよ
逃げないように置いておくことが
しかし その楽しみは決して自分のものにはならないことに気づかない
みんな我がものにしたつもりでしょ
あの人は随分可愛いんだから結婚して私のものにしたんだぞと
なってないんですよ 全然
まあこのすごい高価なカバンは
私はもう回何払い？分割払いで買ったんだから私のものやとなってないんです
あれは カバンはカバンの勝手ですからね
自分のものだったらどうやって空き巣に入ったら盗まれますかね
例えば自分の手を盗んでいくことできないんでしょ？だから我々は本当にいいバカもんで
私のものになったとすごい勘違いしてるんです
ならないんです 自分の体も自分のものにならないんですよ
だって年取りたくないでしょうに
がんになりたくないでしょうに
怪我したくないでしょうに
もう体も体の勝手 自分のものに何もなれません
はい また世間の見方は読むだけで十分です
その楽しみも必ず消えていく
そこでいくらか楽しみに出会っても
これもまた消えていく
それもわからない みんな
その時は別れの苦しみを味わわなくてはならない
真理に気づかない ならないという心理に気づかない
例えば もう期待はずれでも楽しくなってもすぐ忘れてほしいんですよ
突然もうもうもう看板も読めない店に行ってご飯食べたところでえらく美味しかったと
そうすると感動しますよ
これってどういう食べ物か
なんかすごいやけに美味しいなと
しかし その瞬間で十分です
これまた再現しようと思っちゃうとね
それからもうそれで別れなくなっちゃうとかなり苦しいんです
ですから 別れるも苦しみはありますね
楽しみは消える そうと変わらない自分から楽しみは美味しくなくなってしまったと思い思い苦悩する
自分の好きなものがなくなっちゃうと
あー美味しかったのになくなったと苦悩するでしょ
美味しいですか？惜しくですか
惜しく惜しく  美味しいですか
美味しいじゃなくて 惜しく
もっと欲しかったのにということでね
例えば好きな人 親しい人が死んじゃったら
なんで悩むんでしょうかね
なんで悲しいんですかね
いて欲しかったでしょ
だから亡くなったことを惜しいんですよ
それで自分が死なないんだと
私では何のことなくいるのに
なんでお母ちゃんが亡くなったんでしょうかと
と泣くんです だから親しい人が亡くなったと泣くのは愚か者やと平気で仏教は言うんです
親が死んでも息子が死んでも泣くのはバカですと
その時点で笑う笑う笑うほど愚か者ですと
あなたも死ぬんだからと
何考えてるんですか でも
惜しいという気持ちがあるんだから
悲しみが湧いてくる なんで惜しいという気持ちが出てくるのかというと
物事は消えるんだということを知らないんだからなんです
たとえ親であろうが子供だと消えるんだから変化するんだから
それで苦悩して何するかというと
幸福論をあべこべに訂正する
また人生観変わったぞとみんな言うでしょ
うちの息子が事故って死んじゃったところで
私の人生観変わりました
大したことない あべこべに訂正するだけ
どういう風に変わったか
2番目の子はどこへ外へ行くとこ
私は一緒に行くんだよと
同じことでしょう 一緒に行ったってもものは変わりますから
死ぬ時は死にますからね
どこかの子供を誘拐されたり
あるいはちょっとそういう危険に遭っちゃうと
2週間そこら辺の親たちがもうずっと見回りするんですよ
子供をずっと連れて学校に連れて行って
また下校する時でも連れて行って 2週間でやります
私が知っている限りは
子供を誘拐しようとした犯人は次の日も同じ場所には来ない
絶対 だからあれは無駄ですよ
だから危険も何時来るんでしょうかって
何て言いますか 言葉があるでしょう
災いは忘れた時来ると
幸福も同じで災いも同じなんですよ
期待しない時パッと現れるんです
えーと いくつになっても
えーと 小児の精神状態なのです
我々は 過去に引っかかって
いわゆるあの なんかちんぷんかんぷんの幸福感でいるんです
しかし 小児は幼児の楽しみも味わえない
幼児の精神状態なんですけど
幼児の楽しみは味わえないという
そうもいいところなんです
はい で それで「知ってるつもり」と題となると
知ってるつもりは苦しみの道です
人は努力して苦しか増幅させないのです
人間の努力というのは苦を増幅することなんです
後ろ向いて歩くんだから
で 人の考えで発展すればするほど
成長すればするほど 苦のみ発展して成長するのです
人間は頑張ってもらわない方がありがたいと思いますよ
頑張れば頑張るほど苦しみが増えるわ
息苦しくなるわ 金が足らなくなるわ
もう生活苦しくなるわ
自然は破壊するわ 戦争起こるわ
原子爆弾作る もうキリがないんですよ
例えば原発なんかあっちこっち楽しく幸福になるために作るでしょうね
あれでも年 年でも使えないんだから
それから永久的にその土地も全部使えないでしょう
危険ばっかしでね 目が後ろ向きについている限り
人間には人間の問題を解決することが決してできません
人間にはこれできません
目が後ろ向きだから だからこれブッダにしかできない
だからブッダがそれをはっきりしています
人間の苦しみを解決を見つかりましたと
それ見つかった人にブッダと呼ぶんですよ
分かった人やと はい 最後ですかな
それで あの 最後 時間は逆戻しない
逆戻しない 人生にも逆戻しはない
命は今の瞬間に限る 無常を知る人は時間の停止
というか執着ですね を求めない
期待するものは幸福にならない
いわゆる幸福は期待しているものではありません
足元を見ること 見るとそこに幸福がある
それで最後にそれだけで覚えてください
足元見るならば幸福があるんです
限りなく だから仏教は目の位置調整を足元見られるように教えているんです
はい 終わりです さあ それで終わります
わからないところはいっぱいあると思いますけど
[紙をめくる音]